- So it looks like we're
gonna learn a lot more about
why Bill Barr didn't charge
former President Trump
with obstruction of justice.
Judge Amy Berman Jackson has responded
to a FOIA lawsuit by CREW,
the Citizens For Responsible
Ethics in Washington
by aasically saying that the DOJ more
or less lied to the court
about its reasonings
for not moving forward with
obstruction of justice.
You may recall that in front of Congress,
former Attorney General Bill Barr said
that he decided not to
charge former President Trump
in consultation with the Office
of Legal Counsel and the
department's lawyers.
But according to the court's order,
having reviewed the memo in camera,
it appears that the DOJ
and Bill Barr decided not to
charge President Trump first
and then back-filled
everything after the fact.
And as a result,
we may actually see the reasoning
and the memo that went into that decision.
The Biden administration
has 14 days to decide
whether to file an appeal.
Hopefully they won't.
So we'll see the memo and
we won't see them in court.